the ultimate sex in the city trivia
that's right
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i was lucky enough enough to do this
with kristen davis too when she came on
the show which was so fun how'd that go
drew for you not great yeah and i
also like i hope this goes better and
there weren't enough questions i mean
i've studied
most of my life for this yes you have
put in the work and now it's time to
play and the rules are simple i'm gonna
ask you both the series of sex and the
city trivia questions you're gonna buzz
in with your answers uh drew we're
playing for the audience as well you are
playing for that side of the audience
over there
and cynthia you're going to play for
this side of the audience right here
so audience pay attention because
whoever gets the most right wins a big
surprise for their side of the audience
got it all right let's do it
this is very serious business here's
question number one
pay attention it's a two-parter what was
the name of steve's bar and where did
the name come from drew it's scout named
after his dog that is right
[Applause]
number two
there are some french fries in front of
you right there feel free to grab one
and try one if you want it has to do
with this next question after alexander
swept carrie off her feet with a
designer dress and a date to the opera
they went to get fast food from where
these fries are from mcdonald's and it
was an oscar de la renta dress and it
was
because it was all too romantic
alexander petrovsky oh my god she's
right that's two points for drew
okay
question number three cynthia you can
get this okay when when charlotte wanted
to set anthony up with stanford what was
the first question anthony asked about
him cynthia who would play him in the
movie that's right that is
hey guess what we got a game
one point for you two points for drew
all right the next question is a photo
scramble take a look behind us what does
that mean this you'll see right back
here name this beloved late night host
who yeah i'm like okay
andy cohen
who appeared as a barney shoe salesman
it is andy cohen
it is two to two everybody a tie game
here's question number five
what is smith jared's real name cynthia
jared smith
no no it's
jared jarrod
[Music]
i'm jerry jerry jerry jarrod
i'm gonna give you jerry jarrod that is
correct
jerry jarrett i wouldn't expect his real
name yes jerry jarrett that's i knew it
was like a double
and then wow jerry jarrod yep okay the
next question you're gonna need a prop
you'll see there's a post-it note over
there
listen carefully i i think drew and i
don't even need to i know i'm like are
we writing out the posted are we saying
what's on the post because i say it
every day of my life jack burger broke
up with carrie on a post-it what did it
say
can we say it in in unison
yeah okay ready
i'm sorry
don't hate me wait i can't oh
i can't
i'm sorry don't hate me yeah drew gets
that one that's right
[Applause]
the correct order is i'm sorry i can't
don't hate me
drew you're gonna get that point though
okay yeah yeah yeah you get that point
you know what cynthia you're gonna get a
point two because i'm in charge today
[Applause]
right okay starts with i'm sorry i
thought i really only remembered don't
hate me that's all i remember that's the
only important part okay we have a close
game here question number seven which of
these actors did not guest star in an
episode of sex in the city jon bon jovi
lucy liu bradley cooper or wynonna ryder
winona writer
drew
winona writer is right correct
okay here's the final question final
question it all comes down to this
audience who wants to win
here's the final question
oh
and you know what i'm not going to ask
this question we're going to roll it in
instead
hi
ross here's the final question and just
like that is a phrase carrie often uses
in her voiceovers but what is the phrase
that carrie uses in writing her columns
take it away ross
what does that mean so she's carrie
always says and just like that in her
voiceover but when she's writing her
column what does she say i couldn't help
but wonder
the answer is i couldn't help but wonder
okay guess what
the winner of the ultimate sex and the
city trivia showdown is
by a slim margin it is drew
i feel bad i don't ever want to you've
got the jerry jarrod and they're posted
you're good that's what it came down to
was the jerry jarrod yeah well audience
guess what the truth is it doesn't
matter who won because you're all going
home with a 100 spot finder gift cards
with thousands of spas and salons
nationwide
the gilded age on hbo max
[Music]
you